m
dans la continuité de la rencontre qui
s'est déroulée il ya quelques jours dans
l'hémicycle le conseil départemental des
jeunes s'est rendu sur le terrain pour
assister à un contrôle routier avec les
forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'une journée
prévention pour les usagers de la route
et éducation pour les jeunes ici présent
ça ces jeunes deviendront demain nous
porte parole sont déjà usagers de la
route à travers des cyclomoteurs et
aussi à travers en étant passagers des
véhicules
il porte un message alors à leur vrai
nom la première cause de mortalité chez
les 15 24 ans à la réunion et l'alcool
puis la vitesse au volant
il est plus que jamais important de
sensibiliser les jeunes à cette
problématique pour le conseil
départemental des jeunes ce sujet reste
une priorité dans la continuité de notre
convention plex est donc le mercredi
joint ce n'est bien intéressant de
mettre en pratique on avait appris mais
au delà on s'est intéressé à sécurité
routière parce que tout simplement nous
sommes les conducteurs de demain
et ben c'est vrai qu'on conduit pas
encore comme dirait beaucoup de
personnes m'ont quand même c'est bien
faire ont touché les adultes mais étant
donné qu' il ya beaucoup d'accidents
c'est la première cause de morts chez
les jeunes et parce que sur les chaînes
qu'une heure le plus sur la route en
plus bas si forcément nous qu'on doit
sensibiliser le plus en fait
nous apprend m
m
comment ça
tu es
tous ont souhaité
comme si
libre donc ce sont des chats
déjà en fisc et à
un accident
plusieurs actions sur la sécurité
routière sont prévues pendant cette
mandature
il y aura d'autres activités
l'attraction est elle une affiche
à l'arrière des bus et dans les collèges
toujours dans l'action de wendel et
également un spot où les
je vais pas plonger tout jeune par ion
seront eux mêmes le un après-midi sur le
terrain qui a permis aux conseillers
départementaux jeunes de mieux
comprendre le travail de la police et
l'importance d'une conduite responsable